[Applaudissements]
mesdames et messieurs bonjour nous
allons régler ensemble la question de
l'éthique en musique question de liens
qui sont le gérant la musique c'est
l'interprétation si la grossesse
l'apprentissage un dérange tout
particulièrement ce que relier veut dire
ce que ligne et provoque
nous avons repéré à travers quelques
traces digitales philosophique politique
journalistique l'historique comment se
décline l'éthique de la relation des
billets se priveraient par la musique ce
que l'on sait de la musique ce que l'on
fait à la musique classique laisse le
faire de la musique raid l'éthique de
l'esthétique et dont le faire l'éthique
la musique et les fondations
l'éthique est action
quel principe esthétique lié esthétique
la 3d public pourra rechercher
d'intégrer plus que le rcd qu'annonce
mais regardez comme si c'est possible
nous devons régler et qui va l'obliger à
mesure ainsi qu'elodie à suivre le
regard est celui d'une semblable
l'esthétique est politique dans la cité
idéale de patrons on n'autorisera pas
une musique qui dit ce qu'il ya de pire
dans la manière d'être des hommes
[Musique]
jack est une occasion un compositeur ses
caractéristiques la musique tonale
j'espère passer la vague glaciale sais
pas si les différents quartiers d'une
composition sont reliées entre elles
mais si on admet que les
caractéristiques physiques de son biseau
son intensité son timbre et sa durée
alors l'harmonie le fond selon par
intervalles du contrepoint proviennent
non pas des caractéristiques physiques
du centre mais ne l'expriment ces
processus de penser à déception que de
type l'expression était inévitable
l'arrière a nom de la personnalité du
compositeur et l'autre de la nature et
du contexte des matériaux je sentais
plus de fois émanation était plus fort
c'est plus sensibles lorsqu'elle n'était
pas consciemment cherché mais simplement
autorisé à apparaître spontanément je
pensais que l'artiste a une
responsabilité éthique envers la société
sano restés sensibles que sont inscrits
mutuelle de ses contemporains je concède
que s'il le faisait son travail aurait
contraint ci prend une utilité pour
retrouver
vous relier les pratiques musicales à
des questions sociétales et contexte
musicaux rend-il des autorisations
posthume de landerneau en martinique la
structuration des pas de danse créatrice
musicales ont établi par notre
artistique idéal mais l'organisation
sociale il ne pouvait se dire que l'on
la domination des colos cinglant 15-0
dit
après des enfances difficiles à déceler
une organisation est le monde à l hyper
est ratissée
ça m'agace l'exigence de la performance
instrumentale me pousse au caire a donné
des cours individuels je pose une
empreinte musicale pédagogique
institutionnels psychologique gestuelle
esthétique relationnelle
[Musique]
il
julien de la colle de ce qui tient
ensemble de ce qui fait de nous ce qui
fait le libérant de ce qu'il fait un
pont eu la tâche de ceux qui enchaînent
deux ce qui ne laisse pas tout seul il
fait un groupe qui gère un lien
différent et un collant de l'entrée en
matière du fed est déjà entrée en
matière du fait de ne pouvoir pas d'être
entrée en matière du fait d'être des
japonais du fait des rencontres du fait
d'un produit qui passent de l'un à
l'autre du fait d'un pont qui se fait
rentrer la tête du fait du non qui
ordonnait qu'ensemble du fer accord qui
regroupe entre autres un contrat qui
casse les couilles qui va d'un but à
l'autre dû fait un crissement des normes
du japon graisseux attaché contre les
pompes les gens de l'ensemble de l'école
qui ne laisse pas de réveiller de
blessés dans l'état d' réveiller qui ne
laisse pas nous tenir en éveil dans le
guardian illégaux outre les nourrissons
et les 11 secondes qu'il ne laisse pas
de laisser en éveil les éveillés donc il
tâche de tenir tête à julian collant se
rattachent à eau le lien volant
découvrant tous les corps nouvel
emplacement en faisons joseph fritsch
haussière broyait empirique et novembre
volante à son essence
elle table
[Musique]
on
oh
[Musique]
c'est extra
m
[Musique]
depuis des années la musique de ma tête
vois pas rejouer la qualité des
survivants de l'holocauste salue la
décision
le différend par l'opinion du
compositeur qu'elle appelle music inc
highgate dans ces camps de concentration
fémur dû jouer de la musique résistance
aujourd'hui on les plaisirs
là où la musique
je viens parce que le monde
[Musique]
j'ai 1824 d'être une crise à neuvième
symphonie inspirons le texte du poète
allemand fabriquera chez eux dans lequel
on retrouve ces traces helen hill et or
reviennent frères ne s'étaient pas de
vous en tant que le franco argentin a
consacré sa thèse serait politiquement
musique latine mais de détruire le monde
bourgeois
il n'est pas non plus de l' ode à la
joie
nationalisme allemand pour annuler la
puissance symbolique de cette musique
les gars ont reconnu en elle la prime de
mes goûts musicaux
et l'état de la démocratie
[Musique]
cours à écouter mes hormones avec la
même série
après avoir déroulé qu'annick
[Musique]
aujourd'hui compositeur on se bagarre à
tous quel que soit mon la dernière
symphonie des bons orchestres et
ensembles 10h30 à faire surtout que les
outrages du temps
les catastrophes naturelles la volonté
destructrice des en infligeant au liban
des civilisations passées sur nos
propres disparition érosion notre
mémoire lacunaire qu'ils resteront
distincts le choix sur la dislocation du
site et la destruction de la
mondialisation les délocalisations
l'humanisation lippert connectivité nous
indiquant qu'une autre civilisation une
musique et qu'elle nous oblige
[Musique]
saison est il juste est-il morano en
justice est il moralement justifié de
qualifier ce sont deux justes et il leur
a expliqué de qualité ainsi que vos
fausses notes et del moral et on donne
une fille qu'elle conçoit les temps et
si l'industrie
je
[Musique]
on
[ __ ]
je croise d'autres physique je l'écouté
mais l'épousé belge a poussé je manipule
décor sonore je manipule des corps je
l'aï pu notre performance et à l'éthique
[Applaudissements]